and our grandfather left us this creepy
old farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
this is such a phenomenon ghostbusters
is global it expands generations like it
doesn't matter when you were born you
probably have seen this movie
what do you think makes this franchise
so special and kind of makes it all so
timeless to where you know however many
years later people are still going nuts
for the idea of another installment
sometimes you can catch lightning in a
bottle and the original ghostbusters
seems to have done it um why might be
it's probably a combination of things
i think it's a great it's the perfect
cast everybody is great in it
um
it seamlessly blends a few different
genres and it did that at a time that we
hadn't really seen that in quite that
way where something was
kind of scary but also really funny
and
probably
more than anything
the people who made it created it like
the people who were in it and filmed it
wrote it it came from
their own like you know
their imagination it was it and and so
it was made
with the level of care and love and
um craftsmanship that
sometimes you you only get when it's
your own thing so uh every everything
worked it had a killer song
you know that that was
huge when it came out it's played in
theaters for a long time it was unique
and and and that's why it's stood the
test of time
i mean carrie he said a lot but i'll
i'll have anything
well i can say that you know i think
what jason reitman has done really well
is he's maintained that original spirit
that paul just illuminated for us but in
addition and he's also made this thing
very organically i think it feels like
it comes out of jason's love for
something that was part of his family
part of his family legacy his childhood
he grew up on that set and you feel you
feel the love that he's infused the
story with and he took a lot of time
before he decided he was ready to take
on the film i mean it's something he
didn't actively mean to do it just kind
of came to him again very organically so
i think it's it kind of inevitably
maintains that same balance and spirit
of the original film and it invites this
whole new generation in to appreciate it
in such a a smart and thoughtful way and
it just feels like an old school movie
that we all used to see in the theaters
in the you know in the 80s and the 90s
and so i i think it's just the perfect
way i can't imagine anybody else doing
it better
i love that um both of you are obviously
clear fans of uh the series in the
original but um paul start with you do
you have a favorite moment from the
ghostbusters series certain things come
to mind i remember really laughing at
venkman showing the flash cards
i love uh rick moranis a huge sctv fan
and everything
that
rana said in the movie uh
buckled me i'd and still
and and so
you know those are a few things that
kind of stick out
yeah um carrie what about you
i'll always remember the library ghost
i'm i'm somebody who likes to be scared
and it's really hard to scare me so i i
think that's a really great scary moment
in the original film and then i also i
always remember the sequence with
sigourney weaver and bill murray when he
comes to her apartment and she's been
possessed
there's something about the
juxtaposition of that that sort of is um
exactly what the the balance that the
movie strikes is all about a sort of
comedy and horror happening at the same
time and just those two really excellent
actors working together it was a lot of
fun and watching sigourney weaver who's
the sort of elegant presence uh do
something like that that's so sort of
animal and demonic was really fun just
as an actor to it to appreciate now
looking back yeah i think jason said
that this is the scariest movie you saw
as a kid or the funniest movie that you
sort of like saw as an adult and i think
that's like part of the reason why i
think everybody can have a connection
towards it
but also because of it i would say with
this new installment we're sort of
opening things up to maybe having new
folks in it and i'm gonna have to ask
both of you
is there anyone that you would want to
bring into this um into the ghost but
like who would you want to see suit up
with the proton pack it's basically what
i'm saying carrie i'll start with you
oh man oh my gosh that's such a hard
question
but it's a fun one
it's a really fun one no it's really
funny okay okay okay let me think of
like a total badass okay
um let's take a if you got one pause
please feel free to regina king i want
regina king in there with me
that's actually a great one that isn't
it
yeah i'm digging it paul
i'll go i'll just the first person that
popped into my mind was prob was patrick
mahomes because he can do anything oh my
god you had to bring kansas into this
but i respect you for it i really do
anyway one of the other rules of
ghostbusters or kind of rules of
ghostbusters you don't cross the streams
are there any other tips that either you
would like to share um now having been
in a ghostbusters movie and paul started
you yeah maybe don't don't put on a
proton pack until you've really centered
your face yourself you know really like
they
they're
it's not easy they're they're you know
they can be clumsy
by the way i'm assuming i never got to
try one on and i'm still
are you really upset about it
no i'm not upset about it okay i'm like
you got like you've gotten some pretty
cool equipment over the years i know i
have nothing
i have no room to be upset about
anything
my god yeah i got to hold the i got to
be at a movie with these
ghostbusters movie i got to hold a ghost
trap and the chiefs won the super bowl
this is a good year for you i feel it um
carrie real quick for you um what would
you say is advice um now that you've
been in a ghostbusters franchise uh i i
can't give advice like as a ghost like
as a ghostbusters i feel like the rules
are so clearly delineated in the world
of the film but i can say as an actor
if you are going to use a propane pro
proton pack you have to be ready to do
that whatever that gesture is that
implies the power of that thing you know
each of the actors the ogs have their
own style and mckenna kind of found her
style and i think if you're going to put
one of those on as an actor you have to
be prepared to use your whole body in
that way and it's very specific
i found this in my living room
killer replica
a replica of what
a ghost trap i'm hoping you guys had a
pretty good knowledge of ghostbusters
before you joined but what was it like
sort of joining this um universe that so
many people love and how much did you
know about it going in and then i'll
start with you i think mckenna might be
even more of a ghostbusters fan than i
am but i think we're both huge fans um
and uh that really helped uh inform us
like what you know when we did the movie
um
yeah we really respected obviously like
the original source material were giant
fans so it really helped
excellent when was the first time you
guys watched it was it like at home like
i guess i had to be at home
yeah i barely
watched it yeah exactly
no i barely uh remember both of us were
really little so it's it's hard to
remember but my mom has a picture of me
um holding the vhs of ghostbusters
because that's when i first watched yeah
it was always a it was a movie that was
always on in my house it was always on
tv it was always recorded or um i don't
have the specific memory but i have so
many memories i have a lot of memories i
have like very specific memory or not i
don't have a specific number but i'm
like very like i have a collective
memory of just watching it over the
years so yeah that's awesome i mean both
of you
in
incredible careers and just i would say
a short amount of time but you've been
on some big movie sets but i would have
to feel that being on this one
especially with ivan and jason and the
lineage it had to be different so
mckenna i'll start with you what do you
think was different about shooting this
as opposed to maybe another you know big
budget thing like captain marvel or any
of the other stuff you've done well this
is really special because this is
continuing the ghostbusters legacy all
of these years later it's bringing it
back to the big screen
ghostbusters has always been around the
films have always been here but there
hasn't been
like a continuation of the of the second
film or the last films yeah
how how many uses have been like i think
it was 80
88 second one's 80
i mean if it's in the 80s then that's
still a really long time yeah
that's only 40 years for us to make
another
it's not even it's not a remake it's not
a different kind it's a direct
continuation of the second film so it's
really special because it's bringing
back all of this nostalgia and memories
that are
that come with the first ghostbusters
but it's revamped it's newer and it's
it's
it's something that you can introduce if
your kids for some reason haven't seen
ghostbusters already then it's
it's something to re
reconnect people into
into the ghostbusters
idea you know it's this whole the
ghostbusters fans are so cool they're
they're like this big family there's
ghostbusters in every single city like
there's ghostbuster clubs like where
they like dress up and it's the coolest
thing ever you know so many people are
so connected to this film so it's really
special to be able to bring you back
um then i'll ask you because it seems
and i maybe it's just the luck of the
casting or whatever that you've been on
a bit of a nostalgic event either set in
the call to type times for someone like
me or throwing back to it and i'm just
curious you probably know a lot more
about the 80s and like that amblin sort
of timeline than the average 19 year old
and i'm just curious if there's an
aspect you sort of being in the younger
generation are jealous of so like i grew
like i'm sure you don't miss the idea
that we had to like rewind vhs's but i'm
sure there's probably something that was
cool from there
i don't know like all the nickelodeon
cartoons like
uh from the 90s are like
incredible the video games like being
able i don't know just it was a lot it's
a pretty cool time it seemed like more
of like and yeah the music too like
grunge and everything and
uh i feel like
it was also just like a more
uh
yeah there's no global pandemic um that
was cool um
yeah you can like walk outside your
house without feeling scared all the
time in the 90s um
you know like now every now every kid
has a phone and so like if you go out
for like an hour your parents will text
you like where are you that was not
really in the 80s and 90s you would just
leave your house and then come back
whenever you wanted to come back
yeah that was definitely the thing
no i actually yeah it was like you had
to be home by the street light if you
guys are curious exactly what it was
um
uh also um mckenna in again just a short
amount of time you have played alongside
captain marvel uh now ant-man and
captain america and so i'm just gonna go
ahead and be that because we're rotten
tomatoes and this is who we are who do
you think would be the perfect addition
to the ghostbusters like team of those
i know you i know ant-man kind of did
that anyway but like literally like
really like their characters yeah like
they're actual characters not just like
paul rudd or chris evans
who would fit best
or who would you just want on your tv
i mean honestly like i feel like ant-man
would totally which is funny that paul
rudd was in our film but like whenever
you think about it i feel like he'd be
totally yeah he has the comedic thing
like i think you know yeah like just
like just the idea of like his character
being a part of it which pretty much
like yeah paul rudd's character really
geeked out over all the stuff like he
was he was like the
manifestation of the ghostbusters fans
in the film totally i like that no i i
throughout it if you watch him any time
he looks at the stuff he's like that's
cool
that's awesome um and then finno sort of
like switches up for you a little bit
anybody like it seems like maybe we may
be opening up this new universe to
potentially more ghostbusters things you
know that's always the hope whenever
they have something like this come out
um
who would you maybe want to see suit up
with a proton pack
actor or anything yeah yeah like an
actor you'd want to maybe see sort of
join this universe or just maybe i don't
know even characters i don't know i'm
all about mashups here yeah totally um
yeah another character that would be
good i don't know like
maybe
um having i don't know like it's always
fun like having someone that's uh
precocious so i don't know like
be cool you know what i really like you
know be really cool actually is if
um we added just something animated like
we're all live action like like yeah
from um the spider version yeah exactly
like we're all live action then we have
like a member of the team that's
animated
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
first thing congratulations on the film
i guess this is like
a 40 plus year journey he literally grew
up on ghostbusters set so i have to
wonder when did this idea first spring
to you and sort of like when did you
start mapping it out because that's got
to be very intimidating i mean yeah i
mean like you know i'm like anyone who
ever fell in love with the original
ghostbusters film as a kid i've you know
had ghostbusters ideas bouncing through
my head my entire life i never thought
i'd make one of these movies people ask
me all the time you know would you ever
make a ghostbusters movie and i thought
they wanted to see my ghostbusters movie
but the truth is they just want to see a
ghostbusters movie they wanted to see
the pack again the traps again the
ecto-1 fly around the corner they want
to see the guys again
and
when this family popped into my head you
know a 12 year old girl with a proton
pack a teenage boy finding ecto-1 in a
barn
it became a story i needed to tell i
love that um also you know in the intro
that you gave us last night you
mentioned the familial aspect on set so
i'll put it to you this way what was the
best part that came out of having your
dad on set every day and what was the
day that you were like i really wish you
would go on that
all right so the best part is this you
have the world's leading ghostbusters
expert sitting next to you on set and
whether you are trying to figure out the
right color slime whether the tara dog's
moving the same way or frankly just how
to make a better movie i have one of the
world's best storytellers and filmmakers
sitting next to me and that was a gift
that said if you imagine your parents
going with you to work every day and
weighing in on all decisions
that might get a little frustrating
sometimes and obviously
you never want to be caught on set going
dad
so
uh
we had to learn how to be
both father-son and producer director at
the same time but it was the experience
of a lifetime
that's incredible yeah you're definitely
going to be able and honestly a bit of a
role reversal because you cameo and
ghostbusters too so it's like this is
now kind of coming full circle that's
awesome uh you know what i'll i'll give
it to you even better my mother my
sister and i were in the original
ghostbusters but we got cut out
and i we went into the original footage
and found it and we cut it back into
ghostbusters afterlife
oh my gosh oh i think i know where that
is now yeah it's actually in the trailer
of the movie of afterlife and you know
you see paul rudd showing footage to the
kids on a laptop and there's a woman
with two kids running out of a building
and that's us
oh my god that's so great justice that's
what you can do when you have final cut
right like that's the only reason i made
the movie i want to back in
excellent um the next one i definitely
want to ask you kind of alluded to it is
there's something just really special
about ghostbusters i feel like it's just
transcended globe the globe it's
transcended languages anything people
can understand this idea of fighting
wacky ghosts with these
you know these characters and then when
you're doing it again i think that's
still a part of it but what is the
special sauce of sort of ghostbusters
what are the ingredients to make a
successful ghostbusters film and what
were like the cardinal rules you had to
bring into this one
is great question and we spent so long
thinking about this this is a movie made
by hundreds of artists and craftspeople
who loved ghostbusters and
ghostbusters might be the scariest film
you ever saw when you were seven or the
funniest film you ever saw as a teenager
it really is different things to
different people but there's an
iconography to those ghosts slimer the
marshmallow man the terror dog goser the
gatekeeper the key master i mean these
are things that are now part of the
vernacular and we wanted to bring it
back to life in this film with old
ghosts new ghosts old equipment new
equipment this is a ghostbusters film
for everyone whether it's the 100th time
you've seen a ghostbusters film or this
is the first time out i love that um the
other thing i definitely have to ask you
is again you've talked a lot about this
too is the easter eggs and i tried i was
like in it on the easter egg hunt
don't want to give too much away but
what would you say is like if you were
giving someone the top level ghostbuster
easter egg if they can find that and
which one was personal to you
oh wow i mean
okay the most personal easter eggs to me
are strangely the audio ones that we
went back into the original sound files
like we broke open the mix of the
original film and found all the original
pke sounds proton pack sounds the siren
from ecto-1 the own mark no in the score
of the original film i mean all kinds of
sounds that right from the right from
the columbia logo you start hearing
things from the original film and for me
those are very personal easter eggs um
top level easter egg would be
uh
there's that um
there's that hotel housekeeper tag that
venkman had on his office and you can
spot that in uh egon's lab in this film
wow that's a pretty good one um did not
see that and yeah that is like top level
those people had to watch it like 100
times which i know there's people out
there if it makes you feel better i'm
still spotting easter eggs in this film
because every crew member was hiding
stuff on sex
wow that's awesome yeah it feels like
everyone's a part of the joke
not to give uh too much away but you
know like with anything we live in our
new world um there's a whole generation
of folks who are gonna get reintroduced
to this and you got we got more than one
ghostbusters so we would assume we maybe
want to give them more um do you do you
think there's a runway for more
adventures with ghostbusters and better
question who do you think is worthy to
wear the suit oh great questions uh look
i wanted to set the table with afterlife
so i could end up seeing ghostbusters
film from all my favorite filmmakers you
know every culture has their own
relationship with ghosts and i want to
watch all those ghostbusters movies so i
hope this is the beginning of a lot of
ghostbusters movies and
who do i want to wear see where the suit
i mean like all my favorite actors but
also all my favorite directors
oh wow i love that well come on yeah
give me a little bit of name you worked
with some great folks i don't know i
don't want to like because like what if
they end up doing it like i don't want
to like you know what if they say no but
that would even like more embarrassing
i'll say this though
i'm thrilled with who we have in the
suit right now
i'm excited about mechanic grace i'm
excited about film wolfhard i'm excited
about these new actors and logan kim and
celeste o'connor that people don't know
yet and they're gonna fall in love with
them in this movie and see them in
flight suits
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead your dad never mentioned
this to you it's just my mom logan i'll
start with you because i'm just curious
did you have a ton of ghostbusters
knowledge coming into this and if so
you did okay so do you have a favorite
sort of aspect or moment because i feel
like with this franchise it's just it's
special for so many different reasons
man the the library goes at the very
very beginning of ghostbusters one that
part is awesome i was terrified of that
when i was a kid because i always
watched ghostbusters and she always
scared me because now i'm i'm older now
i'm doesn't scare me anymore but
you know
i think just in the movie we had
practical effects and stuff like that
and you could really see the ghost in
front of you and it was really cool so i
love that and celeste for you like i
think jason says it best it was either
the scariest movie you saw as a kid or
the funniest movie you saw as an adult
so walk us through when you first sort
of became aware of ghostbusters and then
also yeah your favorite moment
of course i i saw the
the films as a kid my i saw my family my
younger brother and and it was
terrifying and then when i when i got to
set i was re-watching the films over
again and it was hilarious so jason is
absolutely correct i think i think my
favorite moment is definitely the stay
puft marshmallow man stomping all over
new york city
i love that
so i do have to say with this one so you
guys knew what you were getting into as
far as like the universe and just how
this is like a global thing but
coming on to this set i have to feel
that it was probably different i mean i
know this is you know relatively newer
things for both of y'all but could you
feel it on set how this was going to be
different than anything you probably
have done and definitely probably will
do just because of yeah just how many
people are obsessed with it
yeah yeah i i was going to say i think
that everybody on set really could feel
how
special this story was because
it is not just a movie for
the original fans but it's a movie for
everybody it's a movie for people who
have never even seen any of the films
before because i think that you
you kind of get introduced into this
ghostbusters universe along with all of
these new characters so we could tell
that it was that it's a movie that
really is going to kind of bridge some
some generations because you have you
have the original cast
and then you also have the new
characters and so i think that's like
the beauty of it we there was definitely
a little buzz and energy on set
um
yeah i love that i love how it's taking
um it's taking a continuation of that
story and makes it really interesting uh
logan i'll say with you um again
way to go on your second thing sir
um but uh what was it like knowing that
you're gonna step into this sort of like
so early on
oh
i couldn't believe it like i did fedex
and ghostbusters now like what what is
this
great um
i was just blown away about um
having ghostbusters something i've seen
since i was a little little kid
and having all those those people in
front of me it was surreal
to have that experience and i'm just so
happy it's coming out finally
yeah and folks are gonna get to see it
what's interesting is both of you sort
of had counterparts on set who
strangely enough even though they're of
similar age they've both been working
for a very long time and done a lot of
very big things so logan i'll start with
you did you and mckenna sort of like did
she give you any sort of like i would
say former child actor tutelage on set
to be like when i did captain marvel
just kidding no
no well we made a secret handshake
that's awesome yeah from the very
beginning we became best friends so i
mean yeah uh
throughout the set you can just it's so
funny because
she's like she plays my character in
real life kind of
um not without believing you know
illuminati and stuff but she's very
extroverted and happy and and stuff um
and it's so funny to see her just change
within a scene throughout the movie you
can see our chemistry really really come
together and we're still friends right
now and it is
you can just really see that in the
movie so i think that was my um
favorite moments was just scenes with
mckenna yeah and i mean i'm gonna go
ahead and say it's less there's an
entire i would say
segment of teenage girls who are just
jealous that you got to play a semi love
interest of ben will i'm just gonna tell
them i'm sorry i have to say that
but
more particularly um i just have to
imagine what it was like for you because
that it's a different it's different
feel than you know something like seal
in the states it's just i know that that
first of all is it's coming of age and
then also it's on the big screen but
also having to play with that chemistry
did you guys have to do chemistry tests
and sort of work all that out i think
similarly me and finn just became really
good friends from the beginning i
remember getting on set and i was super
intimidated because you're right i came
right from selling the spades and it was
a really really small set and like one
location
and and i got to the sound stages and i
saw like forklifts and cranes and
construction machinery and i didn't even
realize that a set could like
be that
big and intricate and i got to
i got onto the stage and i met
finn there and he was just like the
sweetest nicest ever and we hit it off
right from the moment we got on set and
so that just made it super easy but it
was it was really great to work with him
too because he does have so much
experience in in these kinds of worlds
and
and so he
was really helpful in in that way
i love that and again i appreciate you
for humoring me but the internet would
have been mad if i didn't say that so
i'll go ahead and end this one
like with any franchise um like this
people are always going to be looking
for new stories and i think if this one
does what's expected to do people are
going to want to see this sort of
universe and these stories expand and
maybe get new characters so i'm going to
ask both of you who would you like to
see in the suit
and maybe strap on a proton pack and
logan i'll start with you i i don't know
for sure
i mean somebody you would just want to
work with maybe
this that is a great answer
[Music]
is amazing i just i want to see more
young women of color in these worlds
that's that's who i want to see with
with the suit and the proton pack and so
i'm really honored and excited to be a
part of this story and i can't wait for
what's next
we're closed